do you prepare for an event like this
differently when you're doing a comics
kid is there things that are off-limits
when you get up there on that stage
tonight oh well well first off I don't
do skits what's the right word skits no
it's it's just improv comedy in general
it's just free you're free it's just
free I think the only way to prepare
because it is improvisation is you just
life is your preparation and you just
come armed with the stuff that you come
armed with and and you and you make
yourself as ready for them as possible
so whatever they throw and the fact that
I know about the organization so if
someone yells something about a trillium
then I'll be able to to do something
with instead of go but that's always the
possibility so you prep on the actual
event and what's gonna be coming towards
you absolutely because you shouldn't but
I had a conference call with with the
producers at at one point and we talked
they were saying oh here's some
information I take that information for
me but that information doesn't
necessarily make it onto the stage
because if someone comes on stage and
and I say hey let's do a scene a song
about your worst day they may give it a
a story about a date that they had that
was a horrible date and it'll nothing to
do with this so this is the framework
but the comedy itself exists on its own
which is the brilliance
well not brilliance I'm not call we call
calling myself brilliance okay no no no
I'm saying it's the brilliance of the
improv art form right is your is your
prepared if you're prepared in life like
James Brown said if you stay ready you
ain't got to get ready yeah so if you
stay ready by reading the news and read
a book then you are armed and ready to
come out and people laugh and talking
about the news it's so interesting to
see how comedians are I don't want to
say they're in the gray area right now
but there's certain things people are
being a little bit more careful I find
now with everything that's happened with
social media and what's happening in the
world right I feel do you feel okay so
you should absolutely and
I think you err on the side of class at
the end of the day and that's just the
way that I was raised I'm from the south
you err on the side of class for example
if if I'm hanging out with my buddy
Jonathan who does the show with me
part of comedies gift is if someone is
sick you you make fun of sickness and
you make fun of death kind of in the old
totemic way of warding it off and taking
away its power I get that but I should
be able to make fun of myself if I'm
sick or of my close friend because
you're my close friend and you get it if
I read a news article about an accident
or something befalling someone and I get
on Twitter and make fun of that person's
bad luck and that tragedy and go but no
it's just a joke what I can't joke
anymore what I can't joke about a
shooting no you can't joke about a
shooting
you they're just in my opinion so this
isn't a room for anyone else nothing
should be off-limits but let class and
tact and human narrative be your guide
something that you wouldn't say to your
kid you don't say to someone else's kids
very interesting no I get off my - no
but it's important you do have this
conversation because it is something
that's been coming up a lot especially
like Kevin Hart the Oscars are this
weekend I mean everything he has to deal
with do you think it was the right thing
to do I can't speak to Kevin's decision
yeah oh only Kevin knows Kevin's
decision I I will say I know Kevin and
I've had the opportunity to work with
him and he is a wonderful guy but that
being said no matter what a good guy you
are everyone has a room to grow we've
all said things in the privacy of
wherever we are that if brought to light
oh my god really you said that it just
so happened he happened to say his
things in his act and he thought they
were funny because of where he of where
he comes from
even where I even where I come from as a
kid it was okay to throw around the
f-word and to call some someone better
to call them out of their name because
to be gay or was to be weak was to be
wrong where I come from also to call
somebody the n-word is to be wrong as be
I watch those things be thrown about all
the time you grow up in that environment
I think it's when you get out in the
world and you're exposed to people you
go oh that God that I would have called
that word too when I was a kid is one of
my best friends I wouldn't say that to
him now so I shouldn't say that to
anybody ever so hopefully he did learn
hopefully he has grown I think he has
probably he's a he's he's he's an
intelligent guy and and so I know it's a
very big issue right now with comedians
because I got to stand up I kind of
stand outside and watch it happen I just
say let taste be your be your guide when
I was creeping you on social media
yesterday and I love the way you stay on
top of everything that's happening and
you're you're using your voice as well
and one of the things I had to ask you
because you did tweet out about
supporting and Jessi Smollett
I'm January 27 yes I did I don't know
how to react to all of this I'm taking
all the information and I'm trying to
figure it out how are you feeling about
it
Oh pissed off yeah can can I say no no
Canadians yeah we use the word Oh
awesome
yes no I'm it's having known just you
just see you the fact that
it could be because I don't think it's
it's cemented yet he's saying that he's
in a sense the police so it's alleged
I'm at this point if also I'll say this
if he did lie if he did place the
struggle of black LGBT people in
jeopardy
if he did but what I was talking to my
friends about was what do you say to
your mom what do you say to your family
on the day that you have to turn
yourself in you're like well I guess the
gigs up how dare you so I'm hoping that
we're wrong I'm hoping that he that
there's some amazing evidence but if not
I'm deeply ashamed of him and for him
and I hope it doesn't stop the fight for
it for treatment of those folks one one
last question Bouldin the beautiful this
is a while back but you were with your
daughter and I thought it was just
amazing because I'm still so far perfect
yeah what was it like to see your
daughter grow and become this amazing
woman and and she sold she it's amazing
to watch your child prosper on her own
and there were days on set when we would
work together when I would actually
leave her alone because it said to me
dad I'm working can I have my space so I
could and I took took offense but she's
a young lady so I feel great I feel
great and I'm proud